so this is 40. this
is 40. happy birthday kim
happy birthday the entire kardashian
jenner fam got together to celebrate kim
kardashian's 40th birthday
with the surprise birthday bash to end
all birthday bashes
yeah just pop up on the pop-up and guys
there was even a choreographed dance
routine all right ladies
five six seven no that's
late kim's mom kris jenner and sisters
courtney and khloe kardashian recruited
the family's long-time party planner
mindy weiss
to help with the soiree which was
chock-full of tributes to some of kim's
most
iconic birthdays throughout the years
narrated with touching home videos
shot by her late dad robert kardashian
epic right just wait because it gets
even better
courtney chloe and younger sisters
kendall and kylie jenner decided to
recreate her 10th birthday bash
choreographed dance and all when kim was
turning 10 years old i was giving a big
party at the house
and i came up with the idea that it
would get all of her girlfriends
to give a performance your friends got
together
and did a little dance to a song that
they wanted
i thought it would be so much fun to
recreate the dance
yeah turns out dancing not really the
kardashian jenner girls thing
all right i didn't sign up for this in
life i didn't sign up to do this
can we just all wear outfits yeah
[Applause]
i have no clue how kylie and i got roped
into this dance because we weren't even
alive
when this actually happened court saved
the day and took the lead while the
other sisters performed a kick line
behind her i'm also the only one that's
good at it at all
we want literature are you on courtney
this is your moment this is your moment
a for effort girls i love it of course
this whole thing was a surprise for kim
and they tricked her into coming to the
party hair and makeup ready
by telling her she was needed for a
photo shoot but when she arrived and saw
ponies and balloons
a nod to her first birthday she got the
hint
ponies and a balloon what the is this
this is definitely not a shoot
look at daddy hi kimberly
as soon as i heard my dad's voice
talking as if it was my first birthday
it all clicked the birthday girl was
treated to different stations from each
throwback birthday
including a halloween themed bash a
retro dinner party modeled after her
eighth birthday at 50s diner ed debevex
and get this they even got the same
white bmw that kim got as her first car
for her 16th birthday
and the party was full of all of kim's
favorite people
all of whom took a rapid covet 19 test
before coming in because of kovid
everyone has to get tested before
entering the party 2020 am i right
real life yeah and the night ended with
the group taking her to a life-size
recreation of tau nightclub where kim
celebrated more than a decade of parties
in her 20s
and 30s oh my god my family
really recreated tao and really outdid
themselves
but before the famous family surprised
kim with the epic get-together
they told her the only celebration would
be a small gathering to tape a
b day special for e included in the
taping
chris chloe courtney scott disick
kendall jenner and
no your eyes aren't playing tricks on
you even kim's brother rob
made a rare on-camera appearance
remember when they called you guys kimye
wait what i still call kim and her hubby
kanye west kimye
anyway the fam took a trip down kimberly
lane
reminiscing on her not so great dance
moves
i don't know how to dance dancer i don't
even like her dancing out like
that oh yeah god what's happening
pussycat dolls
the things i've done are so embarrassing
and
her brief stint as a pop star do we all
remember when kim was a pop star for a
quick second can we not
you remember her song jam right
[Music]
i like literally can't watch it i've
done a little hear myself sing a little
bit
[Applause]
okay
and the celebration isn't over people a
source previously told et that kim whose
milestone birthday was wednesday
brought her friends and fam to an island
on private planes to keep the party
going
it's been so much fun